Welcome to AERA English's Native Maestro.
I'm your maitre d' Seita.
And this program is designed to help you become the native maestro.
Today's Maestro Hook.
The Hook is a good conversation piece you can use with a foreigner...
...to get a good conversation going.
Today, I wanna talk about what I've experienced with Japanese people...
...in a meeting or in a class.
When I'm doing a meeting or in a class, I ask everyone,...
..."Does anybody have any questions?"...
...and then, nobody answers.
I think in Japan, by not answering, you're expressing that you have,...
..."No, I don't have any questions."
But in Western culture, it's more like you're ignoring them.
It's a little bit rude.
So when I say, "Do you have any questions?"
Maybe you should say, "No",...
...or, "Not so far",...
...or, "I'm good".
And this is a good way to have a communication...
...even during a meeting or inside a classroom.
So, please keep that in mind.
Okay. And today's Maestro Menu.
Give me a minute.
And the next one.
That's a tough one.
Oh, that's a tough one.
Let me think.
Yeah, that's a tough one.
Yeah, give me a minute.
So, Maestro Lines.
What do you think of today's project?
Will you think of any good solutions?
Give me a minute, let me think.
How do you feel about that?
That's a tough one.
Give me a minute.
Alright?
So, a good English in a business situation always on Native Maestro.
See you next week and enjoy English.
Bye-bye!